[Music]
we have to write an essay
500 words about who we are i have no
idea who i am
good grief you worry too much charlie
brown
[Music]
long before there was a boy named
charlie brown there was a man
named charles schultz even as a kid i
was cognizant of the fact that there is
a man
somewhere in america who sits at a large
slanted desk
and he draws peanuts peanuts is just its
own
planet i related to charlie brown so
much
i think charlie brown is just a little
bit of what all of us have
inside of us my favorite character is
lioness
i used carry around a blue blanket
everybody knows what lucy with the
football means
god i love snoopy he's so cute
i've been dreaming about this thing
since i was about six years old he was
the little kid
that no one really talked to he was
one person telling this personal story
every day
[Music]
like all the best creators there's a lot
of himself
in the work i remember i called him my
sweet baboo
pretty soon it was in the comic strip i
mean he he was those characters
i have to figure out the meaning of my
life the meaning of life is to give and
receive
love i feel like he always was searching
for the truth and wanted the world to be
equal
you saw the girls in sports which is a
girl i'm like oh that's great here i am
reading this comic strip and all of a
sudden there's a kid in there that looks
like me
it was 1968 papers threatened to drop
the strip
and he's like fine drop it the
conversations those young children have
resonates to our soul as successful
as he was i don't know that he got the
full depth
of the love and devotion people had to
him and those characters
keep on trying charlie brown never gives
up and if anybody should give up he
[Music]
should
[Music]